you said
that public sector pay policy has been
misrepresented by the media here's the
proposal that you released introduce
regional pay boards tailoring pay to the
cost of living where civil servants
actually work saving up to 8.8 billion
pounds per year so how have we
misrepresented you so far well what what
i am clear about
is that policy was not about teachers
and doctors but can i be clear kay that
i'm not going ahead with this you can't
but you said you were because i'm just
clarifying because because of the
concerns that have been expressed okay
and when something is just clarified
when there's an issue okay i deal with
it okay but just to clarify whether you
were misrepresented or not you
highlighted a very specific saving 8.8
billion pounds how did you reach that
figure
well i don't have the details and i do
think discussing a policy that i'm not
privileged obviously these people it's
it's very pressing for these people
certainly some of them so we just want
to bottom it out and then we're
definitely there and i'm sure you won't
have to answer these questions again
it's exactly the same figure the 8.8
billion that was issued by the taxpayers
alliance they say regional based pay
could allow private sector salaries to
catch up with the public sector this can
be done by freezing or reducing pay for
existing roles and new
positions in other words pay cut for
nurses doctors firemen police officers
in less affluent areas which is what
this gentleman was saying
that wasn't what you were proposing
you've changed absolutely that was not
my intention but given the concern that
was caused i took an immediate decision
not to proceed with this policy okay
i am somebody who immediately
if there are issues of concern and those
are
not delivering what i want to deliver i
will
make a decision to do the right thing
and that's what i've done not just this
gentleman here but ben houch and the
conservative mayor of ties valley said
there's no way you can do this without a
massive pay cut for five and a half
million people including nurses police
officers and our armed forces outside of
london
do you accept
that you made a mistake by announcing
the policy
i do accept that the way the policy
has been interpreted to cover those
people was not right and that's why i
took an immediate decision not to go
ahead with it you offended people though
you misread the mood you accept that it
was a mistake
what i've said is i absolutely accept
that it wasn't the right policy to deal
with this situation and therefore i
withdrew the policy immediately and i'm
somebody who is honest and up front k
i dealt with the issue immediately after
the concerns were expressed about how
this policy had been interpreted and
i've dealt with it straight away okay it
was a mistake though well as i've said
i've withdrawn the policy we're not
going ahead with the policy so therefore
you know
the the points you're making are about a
policy that isn't happening no no what
i'm saying is should good leaders own
their mistakes
um or should they blame others
i'm not blaming you blaming anybody else
i'm not i'm not
i'm saying that um the policy has been
misrepresented by various people but
what i don't want at this time when
people are struggling with the cost of
living is to concern people with this
policy which isn't a core part of my
policy platform and i'm not going ahead
with it okay let's talk about the
economy see as we've moved on to that um
i want to talk to you about your plans
to help the worst off if i may we've
spoken to selena she's a single mom in
the northeast of england she works
part-time to support her three children
and earns just over ten thousand pounds
a year
what will you do to help her
when her energy bills reach 500 pounds a
month in january so first of all i'll
take immediate action to reverse the
national insurance rise and help so
won't help her she earns less than
twelve thousand five hundred and seventy
pounds so she wouldn't she won't also
the green energy levy will be taking
that's 150 pounds and her bit and so
that's a drop in the bucket really isn't
it and what i really want nine days of
energy for her and what i will also do
is work to increase the amount of
supplies we're getting out of the north
sea so that we can get more gas into our
system so we can move forward on dealing
with the energy crisis and energy
security because ultimately
ultimately
these problems can only be dealt with by
first of all making sure putin is
defeated by the ukrainians so that we
don't have this energy supply problem
and also
by releasing more reserves in the north
sea i'm also in favor of fracking in
areas that support it so we get more of
our own domestic energy supply but what
i can assure you k
is i will do all i can to help people
who are struggling with the cost of
living
i understand that people are going
through difficult times and if there are
any more available resources of course i
would put that to helping people with
the cost of living let me tell you
something
these are selena's words i'm really
worried about how i'm going to keep my
children warm and fed this is going to
cost lives if they don't do something
now
but this is why it's so very important
that we
offer support to businesses that we it's
not going to help her well it will help
her because
the real danger we're in as a country
and this is what the bank of england has
said today is we're facing a recession
and what a recession would mean is
people losing their jobs businesses
going out of business people struggling
across the country so that's why it's so
important we do things like keeping
corporation tax low keeping personal
taxes as low as possible
getting things like infrastructure
projects done quicker to grow the
economy that is ultimately the way we
are going to deal with this crisis is
through economic growth okay here's an
idea what about the windfall tax shell
posted profits of 9.3 billion pounds
between april
and june if we put that another way
shell made 1 190 pounds per second so
since i started this sentence they've
made 17 000 pounds in profit why don't
we have another win full tax well the
problem with the windfall tax
is that it might secure money in the
short term but what it does is it puts
off companies investing in britain in
the long term because they think they
wouldn't they think at any point
they could be taxed and i think that is
a problem what we need to show is
britain's open for business we're a
country that keeps to our word of what
our taxes are and when full taxes are
essentially surprise taxes that
companies don't know that are happening
what i would do instead kay
is make sure we're incentivizing the
likes of shell to be
releasing more resources from the north
sea to actually help the problem that we
face which is a lack of energy supply
they had a bp said that he would
continue to his business would continue
to invest if there was another win
full-time
it's not just bp though it's the signal
that it sends to every business across
the country that the government is
willing to give you a surprise tax and i
think that is a problem for britain i've
already talked about how our corporation
tax rate is uncompetitive compared to
other countries if we also have a
reputation for levying a surprise tax on
any industry that makes a profit that is
a big problem for our country shell is
giving their um shareholders 6.5 billion
pounds
people at home watching who can't afford
to heat their homes uh come the winter
will be horrified at that
look at who these shareholders are these
shareholders are often people with
pensions you know pension funds
shareholders are not you know all sort
of men in sitting sitting in offices you
know
there is a real
there's no such thing as free money and
i just think we've got to be very
careful if the uk gets a reputation for
arbitrarily taking money in tax that
we've not sort of done through the
official tax system i think that's a
problem okay let's move on to foreign
affairs we've talked about it a little
bit do you want the step of water you're
very welcome um talking about taiwan i'm
sure that we've all seen haven't we
what's been happening in taiwan over the
last few days
um as foreign secretary you told the
select committee last month that we
should have armed ukraine earlier
should we arm taiwan no
well what we do need to make sure is
that democracies like taiwan are
defended
and yesterday i put out a statement with
my fellow g7 foreign ministers about the
very difficult situation in taiwan and
concern about the rhetoric that we're
hearing from china the escalatory
rhetoric of course we have a very
uh a very secure
control system for exports in the united
kingdom and we do license exports to
taiwan
at the moment
exports that are provided by the private
sector so should we arm them or not well
what i'm saying is we already license
equipment to go to taiwan okay and
there's a long-standing policy of the uk
government to do that okay you said uh
to the foreign affairs select committee
in june uh month before last we should
have done things early we should have
been supplying the defensive weapons
into ukraine earlier we need to learn
that that lesson for taiwan every piece
of equipment we have sent takes months
of a training so the sooner we do that
the better so just to clarify we do
license um arms that go there but that
is that is as far as we're going to go
at this stage
yes
that is as far as we will go at this
stage but we are working with our allies
very closely on this because there are
countries like the united states japan
okay who
also
are extremely concerned about the future
of taiwan okay and what we need to do is
work collectively and i have championed
the g7 acting together as an economic
nato to challenge some of china's
economic coercion practices but also to
make sure we're looking at the security
situation and making sure democracies
like taiwan are protected i'm sure you
can understand kay that i can't go into
every detail of those conversations
because on tv
but it's a it's a very important
principle that we do not allow
aggressors to
to invade you know democratic democratic
places we've seen nancy pelosi another
strong influential woman in taiwan this
week will you visit taiwan if you're
prime minister
uh
we we currently have a long stand yes or
no
really no
uh we we we have a long-standing
position that the foreign secretary the
ministry of defense and the prime
minister don't visit let me talk to you
about uh ukraine was it an era of
judgment to say you'd support brits
going to fight in ukraine what i was
very clear about is that i supported the
cause
of the fight in ukraine but i've always
been clear
that the travel advice is that british
people should not go to ukraine no what
you said was i do support that when
zelinski called for international
volunteers ukrainians are fighting for
freedom not just for ukraine but the
whole of europe and you did support
people you did support brits going to
ukraine to fight well what i suppose you
have to be correct what are your own
defenses what i was saying
is that i supported the cause in ukraine
okay your foreign office website said
brits traveling to fight in ukraine
could be committing an act of terrorism
did you know that when you said it
well what what i've said is that i
support the cause in ukraine and
actually i've done a lot of work to
support british citizens who have been
detained in ukraine who've been there in
the long term and the foreign office has
provided those people are you sorry that
people misinterpreted what you were
saying
well what i have said is that the
defense the advice was very clear the
travel advice was very clear and i
announced that publicly that people
shouldn't go to ukraine but i think what
is happening clearly because we spoke
about poland who were going into ukraine
who were brits that had crossed the
border and were then subsequently going
into ukraine well many you know there
had been many british people going into
ukraine okay during the war but we are
very clear about our travel advice okay
i've got some quick fire questions for
you if i may here we go in your first
meeting with the queen will you
apologize for wanting to abolish the
monarchy well i've already
i've already met the queen and she's
been far too polite to raise that issue
with me and i will not be uh i will not
be raising it with her okay but if she
did would you apologize
well i was wrong uh i was wrong to say
what i did at the time okay will you be
apologizing to the first minister of
scotland when you see her
no i won't
uh what's the naughtiest thing you've
ever done i'm certainly i'm certainly
not going to say that on tv oh was it
that naughty
well my daughters are watching so i
don't want them i don't want them
getting any ideas okay
being prime minister is the most
invasive um exposed period in any
politician's life is there anything that
you feel that you would want to come
clean with the audience here in the
studio and at home because there's no
one else listening so it's all fine i
can just tell anything that you need to
get off your chest
there are i can tell you okay there are
no skeletons in my closet i think
everything i've ever said and done is
known about very publicly
would you remove the whip from boris
johnson if he's found to have
deliberately misled parliament over
partygate
um i'm not making any prejudgments about
that why not well i'm just i'm not
making prejudgments i'll see what the
committee says but if they say
deliberately mislead parliament as i say
i mean i'm i'm i'm not making any
pre-judgments about okay what one change
by the way i'm very clear he didn't
mislead parliament well we'll see what
the business what the committee says
what one change to the system
would you make to restore
integrity because there's a lot of
people here in the studio
thank
uh you just here in the studio but
watching at home as well you know
integrity has been lost in the
westminster bubble what would you do to
change it well i think the the answer to
restoring integrity isn't introducing
more rules because we have endless rules
and codes the issue is
about clarity
and leadership and doing what you say
you will do and following through on
your promises what i would also do as
prime minister is restore the chief whip
to number 12 downing street the chief
whip was moved out by aleister campbell
and replaced with the press office i
think that was a mistake because it
reduced the link between the prime
minister the chief whip and the
parliamentary party and i would make
sure
i i would make sure we had zero
tolerance for bad behavior in the
parliamentary party but we're also
supporting mps because as you say you
know being prime minister is an exposed
job but actually being an mp at the
moment is pretty difficult you know
there's all kinds of difficult things
said about you on social media and it
can be very difficult for people's
family lives so at the same time as
making sure we have discipline and
you know making sure people are honest
and behave themselves we also do need to
offer mps that welfare and a new ethics
advisor
and you stand by if you would a new
ethics advisor
well i will i will look at the role of
the ethics advisor but
i'm somebody who
does act with integrity and i think
people have seen that in every job i've
done and i slightly worry about
outsourcing ethics to somebody else
as prime minister
i should know
the difference between right and wrong
and of course there need to be proper
independent complaints procedure there
needs to be proper whistle buying
procedures but i would want to look at
how how those things are structured okay
you were loyal to the pm despite parties
during lockdown
or when he promoted a man who groped
colleagues
or when he was rewriting the rules to
help out his mates
throughout that you stood
shoulder to shoulder with a man who has
betrayed the office of prime minister i
don't agree with that characterization
kay
i supported i supported boris johnson
for the leadership i think he did a good
job as our prime minister he delivered
brexit he delivered the vaccines he also
uh did a fantastic job of leading the
free world in standing up to vladimir
putin in ukraine yes he made mistakes
that's absolutely true you know he he
said sorry
for the mistakes he made but i think
it's completely wrong to characterize
him in that way
i don't know what does the audience
think
yeah agreed agreed agreed no no no
okay
i think it's opinion opinion is divided
on that issue i think we can hear we can
hear from from people in the audience
but i have worked closely with boris
johnson i know the difficult times he
went to you know he was in very serious
trouble
when he had covered and you know it's
been a very very difficult time to be in
government but look you know many
mistakes were made during lockdown okay
um you know by by many people and i just
think to sort of say that
this was the
you know crowning problem is it is not
right yeah so i'm in charge of policy
some not a final question for you just
before we let you go you were a remainer
and now you're not you supported uh
brits to fight in ukraine then you
didn't
you wanted to build on the green belt
and now you don't you wanted to abolish
the monarchy and now you don't you
wanted to arm taiwan and now i'm not
sure if you're saying whether you do or
not you wanted civilization we do
provide
those you wanted to cut civil servants
pay in the regions and then you said you
didn't
will the
real
liz trust please stand up
okay i i'm somebody who you know i
didn't come from a traditional
conservative background my first
political experience was going on a cnd
march with my mother age seven you know
i then
uh as a teenager joined the liberal
democrats i'm not sure how much i should
be held to account for things i said
when i was 18 or 19. but i've always had
a belief
that
we can be
a more successful country that people
should be able to control their own
lives i've always believed in the
principle of freedom i've always
believed in low taxation yes
my views on other issues have developed
over time but show me somebody who has
the same views at 19 and 49 and i'll
show you somebody who's not capable of
original thoughts so yes you know i have
i have you know developed my views i've
considered things differently and i also
listen to people okay and i think that's
important so what we've been talking
about today any time we have to give the
policy as i've given you the same amount
of time i did say well the real this
trust please stand up you're still
sitting down
that's just because you're trying to get
rid of me
please thank you very much
[Applause]